welcome to this video run one coverage
of the candidates tournament if
cantonments Ascan we're looking at the
game kayaking against Sevilla two of the
sort of mid tier players in this
tournament who sort of yeah are not
heavy favorites but certainly are
capable of doing good things if they
will start well in this tournament and
only wind can often get you get you
going
alright so um a bit surprising for me is
that this witless playing this variation
here he goes for as the Sonia and he
placed them yeah mostly called tamaño
variation here with 96 this is one of
the lines that has some more than one
name they're also people calling it the
the Paulson variation and turn and
others um it's not one of the regular
lines that spitless playing he is
playing if he goes for the sassoon he's
playing the clown variation with six and
A six always playing the night off and
okay he is also a 1.e4 e5 double King
pong player these are double King pawn
and the night off are his main main
openings but okay he's doing something
different here 96 he has played it
before it's not like completely a new
opening but it's nothing that I guess
was very high on the list of openings
that coyoacán have to prepare him so 93
Queen c7 Bishop e3 yeah
the signals White's intention to set up
a position that is typical were
typically called the English attack with
the Queen to d2 later f3g for long
castles it's called the English attack
because it was introduced and
popularized probably introduces the
wrong word because
they were yeah people playing it even in
the 1970s but in the 1980s by um British
players
Nigel shorts John none Murray Chandler
couple of strong British GM's they have
played this successfully mostly against
the night off but it has been becoming
even more popular nowadays against all
kinds of Sicilian setups and also
against the the time on/off switch is
playing a six year here black actually
has a choice he can play a six on Knight
f6 in the early days of the slide a six
has been more has been more popular but
in recent years Knight f6 has gained
some momentum the idea is that if white
goes some for this quick Queen side
castles then black quickly gets play
with Bishop reform he's also playing
like that with a six but it's not clear
that a six is a move that he necessarily
needs to play here so the ideas in a way
to save a tempo in the fight for the
center and it is turned out that White's
most popular move against Knight f6
nowadays if the F form sort of mixing
systems of course f4 and the Sicilian is
pretty common move but white is now
abandoning the idea of going for this
English set up with f3 and g4 and get
the reason why I'm telling all this is
sweet Allah actually played a6 the
Ottomans
after which Queen d2 was played Knight
f6 and now in this position absolutely
I'm by far the most popular move is long
castles after which black normally plays
Bishop b4 and then we have something
like this f3 and now the most popular
way to place to move this nice to e5 or
to e7 possibly intending to play d5 note
that it is not really advisable if you
this position would like to play d6 this
transposes to something typically called
as evening information with the e6 and
d6 but here in this line where white
quickly pushes on the kingside the move
Queen c7 which is quite normal looking
it's simply too slow this is not a good
line for black if you play this term
on/off setup with the bishop slope being
able to go to before against this line
you really shouldn't play the six and
use this bishop opportunities um karaoke
no ever didn't play long Castle he
played the move and form and of course
and what I'm telling now is the result
of some research because I'm not an
expert but I learned that this is
actually a remnant of f4 which surprised
me it looked perfectly normal to me but
it is rarely played probably the idea
too to play it was um popping up here
because of the other f4 idea that I
showed before in the position where
actually a six and twenty two was not
played so on this is a new twist in in
this opening or let's say an unexplored
twist less explore twist I've found like
twenty games with this move this will
deplete b5 yeah perfectly logical
typical Sicilian with the alternative is
of course Bishop b4 as you probably have
guessed from there from the other
positions that I've shown now now
there's an instant threat on e4 and
white also cannot really go forward as
94s terribly awkward for white so you
need to protect your center Bishop d3
and here probably a black has more than
one opportunity but a recent again that
I found from the
open open tournament often Gibraltar
what sir played with Knight a5 after a
three now this should take some retakes
Jack Queen takes B takes and d5 black
had quite a solid position this was
played between the French Grandmaster it
won very strong GM to 660 around you
know I'm against one of the top female
players of Georgia this is a terrible
name to pronounce for me yeah okay
should we leave Leia Hyuk Hyuk is really
tricky
without any practice before and she
managed to draw this game still being
200 points lower rated um this is an
alternative that could have happened but
Svidler didn't play Bishop defy played
b5 and now on eight which is pretty
early
we are already in pretty pretty little
exploit territory there only about I
still care for eight or nine games with
this so on probably I guess a position
that they didn't analyze some heavily at
home note that clock times they both
haven't used much time up to now but now
it after a couple of moves they will
start to spend time yeah kayaking played
five now which is I guess the logical
move what else is there
black is threatening before winning the
pawn on e4 and you don't really want to
play Bishop d3 it does not make so much
sense so II five is the way to go it it
takes the knight and it does not have
any central squares to go here sweedler
played Knight g4 also fairly normal
looking move there also is before him an
interesting counter-attack that
initiates
transformation in the position as white
of course does not want to move the
night if he okay let's say he does not
want to move it back White's best move
and the move up late yes and I'd be five
but you don't want to move it back for
example and say here giving blackness
excellent square on d5 so white oops
sorry after before he just placed night
b5 in order to get gain those tempos on
the Queen and only then take on f6 yeah
I tier after he takes f6 G takes f6 we
have reached the position that has been
played only last year between two strong
younger grandmasters white player was
Eric Hanson from Canada very promising
Canadian player and some Shanklin from
the US who you also might known no he
has played a couple of US Championships
successfully both are around 2600 rated
yeah this is a very complicated position
of this limb where we have equal
material but completely unequal
positioned white has free against one
pawn here on the Queen side it's a messy
position the King only eight and in this
game it turned out to be a good for
white but it was a very very tough fight
that was happening between those two
players so this is what's really did not
play
he played Nagi 4 and look at the clock
he was playing really really quickly so
he had some some sort of preparation for
this Kuryakin played Bishop g1 also
quickly um yeah and this is a pretty
much forced move you cannot allow like
to take on e3 it's giving up to bishops
for no compensation and it's not just
the bishop thing it's the darks quest
you cannot afford to give up this bishop
self Bishop Sivaji one is forced it's
not a big deal to get it back to the to
the
Frank white will castlelong anyway and
white will also win time against this
night and then the bishop might get back
into play again that's no problem to
have it back on g1 yeah Bishop d7 you're
pretty much what else kind of move the
long diagonal this is black strong card
after white s-some well this isn't
awkward I don't know the long diagonal
after white is pushy five this is
obviously wide open and this is where
black needs to initiate his play
yeah Mon castles was played Baron and
now swiller took on d4 what black
absolutely must avoid is a situation
where white has played a tree and g4 and
the knight is stuck on h6 I can just to
show the general idea played Bishop e7
Bishop III and his villa already took
very strong measures against this
happening let me just show what I'm
talking about if let's say black would
cancel just for argument's sake white
place looks like a three right to here
and look G one just to to have to have
the idea shown if black now plays and
nothing like that white will play d4 and
this Knight is an absolutely terrible
shape it has no square to go to and
Dwight has all the makings of a heavy
King side attack coming f5 and so on so
you must take some some measures to make
sure that you're not getting into
trouble with this night on g4 and
speedla is playing a very direct move
against that and five note now they both
had 35 minutes spent though they're on
their own now cannot rely on concrete
preparation
he played f5 as mentioned and this is in
fact a move that I personally like but
it's if you look at it with with the
computer and I'd say I use Houdini form
multiprocessing version the pro version
whatever so pretty strong engine on a
strong computer and it is not like the
movie it does not want to want to play
it but after having analyzed city but
I'm not quite so sure why it doesn't
like it it gives white slight edge after
that I personally like it because it
does do two things and makes sure that
the knight has returned it blocks the
bishops nicely yeah okay white can take
off on so we can look at this shortly
and what it also does the jobs like you
white in this position cannot use the e4
square anymore like 94 at some stage is
not possible because the pawn is just
controlling the square and white can
take to open up the bishops and note
that in this close structure both
bishops are looking at here a wall of
pawns so this is not an entirely
illogical move but look at this it
happens that this is almost forced and
black has nothing to complain about here
he's got a good knight on f6 now it has
returned from g4 nicely protecting the
King side and black has decent player
this is a good diagonal you have before
coming nothing special to fear him so
the capture is very untested yeah I
think I Aachen is playing it just better
not taking he played to h3 and sent the
knight back to h6 rook g1y a very
logical you need to play g4 at some
stage and this will adjust castled and
now Queen to e3 it's funny if you look
at the database you will actually find
exactly one game where this position it
was on the board but I don't think that
the players were aware of that was a
game between a player I think is from an
Austrian player called fought against
new cheese cool new cheese play with two
2,450 is black and the white player was
the 2050 player so black was a heavy
favorite and and won the game later in
this game they had played King b1 said
of Queen III it was some quite
comparable to the to the main game but I
don't think that we are talking about
home prep here they spent far too much
time to that so it's just a coincidence
that those move has had been played
before and they're very logical I mean
some of them were forced and the other
others really other first moves you you
can think of so Queen III was some
kayaking smooth and this is probably a
multi-purpose move it controlled c5 so
black cannot easily play Bishop c5 for
example I don't really think this was a
threat but this is one idea to have the
bishop here on this diagonal support the
bishop for possible action on this
diagonal of the Queen might swing over
to g3 after G foam has played and it
also increases the influence on the
center of it yes we have played rook c8
very normal-looking move and now king b1
yeah this is one of those cases where
you feel inclined to play this move to
cover a two for example if you look at
the further cause of the game where a
bishop appears on d5 later there will
always be the same to pawn hanging so he
protected this in advance bishop c6 yeah
a move that allows Queen b7 emphasizing
the long diagonal and after before it is
made sure that the White has not Knight
a four available and so now we went 92
retreating the night just before before
was coming
in fact here the computer has an
interesting suggestion which I really
like it wants to play and somewhat
differently
g-46 which is pretty normal but now it
comes up with the idea to play with it
too and this is an interesting idea it
has yeah it's a multi-purpose move the
rook might come handy on the second drag
if you think about g5 and h4 you might
have rook h2 to further support the H
pawn note that h1 is always controlled
by by the bishop so you cannot just put
the rook on h1 this is one idea and the
second idea of rook t2 is then after
before you can drop the knight back to
d1 which is in fact quite clever I
believe because if you look at before
I'm not quite sure that this is even
such a great move to be honest if you
look at before it has one drawback it
weakens the c-4 square and why it now
has the idea to play something like that
and say here yeah yeah Knight to be to
so the knight will get some yeah some
good square on c4 a very interesting
positional idea which I believe that
black should be aware of and he probably
I'm not sure if he should play before
even maybe it's better to to do some
more preparation book so that night D 1
to B 2 to C forth and it's not not
coming so quickly
but I don't think that black necessarily
needs to play before this exact moment
he can also play play other moves to
improve the position let's say Queen b7
for example just for argument's sake
yeah white white still has those ideas I
mean it it feels like maybe white has
has a little bit a little bit of
pressure here I like this more than
kayaking smooth the plate and as
mentioned 92 sort of
prophylactically moving it the way but
now Bishop t5g former g6 now he played
b3 yeah probably
being a bit unsure if Bishop c4 is a
move you should prevent or not so we put
upon on b3 to control the square I think
that here it's not it's not so evident
if if white really has something if he
pushes with g5 for example and you look
at in this position there is this queen
a5 counter play and this is really
serious
if white play something like b3 for
example you might even get the knight
back into the game and actually attack
white so it's there is some point to to
playing b3 M so this is what he did and
now Queen b7
yeah but them with some ideas it opens
up the C file for the rook we see a
technical point of that later another
idea might be that you actually have
those squares now for the bishop so this
might come in handy as well play the
rook to everyone covering a3 amongst
others again is not going for g5 now
after this here for example I don't know
if I like to smooth this is a
possibility but it looks strange just to
stop h5 but after this you don't really
have a good square no probably not lying
not do that yeah maybe black can play D
6 cm yeah but it would open up this
diagonal right yeah it was so
interesting to do that I mean what I
actually believe is that kayaking played
to be honest he played too many prep
moves see if he maybe should just play
g5 and
and see what what happens played rook f1
as mentioned just another prep move and
now smoothly I went a five yeah what
else is there need to do something on
the Queen side and now Nigeria was
played so again not g5 yeah and here a
switch I played a really surprising move
I was a I was really taken aback by that
he played Bishop to c4 and really
strange but yeah it has some point White
has this bishop on d3 and yeah black
probably will just initiate an exchange
here white cannot take this is check a
check and it gets awkward so on again
what what is actually white smooth via
kya Kehna responded with a very a very
cunning cunning reply um yeah I played
Bishop to e4 just putting it on this
controller square and this really
surprised me but yeah he did that I mean
he does not need to play this movie can
play em play other things he can now
play g5 it does not make so much sense
to be honest in connection with all
those moves like rook I have one but him
you can do it and initiate the fight
here probably a four you know and it
gets interesting black has some attacker
on his own and it's not like black is
mated quickly yes some good defensive
pieces as well and those pieces here
they can only be used against Blacks
king by sacrificing on f5 or H violence
and things like that so it's entirely
unclear
he played Bishop before as mentioned and
this is really quite a shock yeah and
here we come to the point where sweet
love is the one two T's to decide what
to do because he can play Bishop d5
which he did after some thought after
Bishop d3 he played Bishop c4 to repeat
moves
the thing is after worship before black
now look at this relay at ten minutes
more on the clock he could have played
ticks of course it's an interesting was
just taking the bishop off and it leads
to one really unclear play B takes root
chicks yeah white needs to get the piece
back
so in mistake rook takes Knight takes
only four and this is completely
completely unclear position with the
computer give some black slightly the
better chances here but to be honest it
is it is really completely unclear you
have a situation where you don't like
this Knight here White has f5 as a
possible attacking idea Knight f6 as an
idea but of course it's not like
plackets without any play can play rook
c8 here for example directly attacking
it can play something like that to go on
a two so it's it's getting really really
sharp and yeah the thing is suela didn't
do it he didn't I don't know had the
courage or whatever and was content with
the draw in the first round and he
played Bishop d5 back to complete a
threefold repetition and refutation
repetition
I don't think the game is showing drawn
here I'm not sure if this is correct
I think they should repeat one more time
to make it a three fault um yeah bit of
a disappointing quick end to this game
which could have been really interesting
if speedla decided to do fry it on with
F takes e4 instead of allowing the
repetition I think one important point
is really it is the first round and you
hate to lose the first round to to make
it an uphill struggle so I understand
that you probably don't want to risk it
all but at some point you have to win
game so and take some take some chances
so
bit of a disappointing end to this game
alright I hope you enjoyed it anyway an
interesting fight at least through the
first twenty something moves thanks for
watching